hey this is presh talwalkar
this flower math problem is said to come
from a chinese test for five-year-olds
after it was posted online it created a
huge debate as people could not agree
upon the correct answer
can you figure it out
give this problem a try and when you're
ready keep watching in this video i will
present what many people consider to be
the correct answer
to get started you want to look very
closely at the pictures
in the very last equation the first
picture shows one yellow flower
this is not the same as the equation
before which has two yellow flowers
now look at the blue flower in the last
equation
there are four petals on this flower
in all of the other blue flowers there
are five petals
arguably these differences mean the very
last equation cannot be evaluated
however we can try and assign a
consistent value with all of the other
information in this problem
let's try and do that
the first equation has three red flowers
equals 60.
this means one red flower is equal to
20.
the next equation has a red flower plus
two blue flowers equal 30.
we can use the value of 20 for the red
flower and then we have 20
plus two blue flowers with five petals
equal to thirty
we subtract twenty from both sides so we
have two blue flowers with five petals
equaling ten
if we count each petal as a value we
have a total of 10 blue petals
so we can assign a value for a blue
flower as saying it's equal to 1 per
petal
the next equation has a blue flower with
five petals minus two yellow flowers
equal to three
we can assign the blue flower with five
petals a value of five
we then are subtracting two yellow
flowers to be equal to three
this means that each yellow flower has a
value of one
now we'll use this information to try
and evaluate the last expression
the yellow flower will replace with the
value of one the red flower will replace
with the value of twenty
and the blue flower with four petals
will replace with the value of four
we have one plus twenty times four
twenty times four is equal to eighty and
we add 1 to get our answer of 81.
did you figure out this tricky problem
thanks for watching this video please
subscribe to my channel i make videos on
math and game theory you can catch me on
my blog mind your decisions which you
can follow on facebook google plus and
patreon you can catch me on social media
at preshtalwalkar and if you like this
video please check out my books there
are links in the video description